la politique a besoin de visages
nouveaux des lui qui vous ressemble et
qui sont ancrées dans la vraie vie elle
est passionnante si elle est menée au
service des autres j'ai décidé d'être
candidate aux prochaines élections
législatives pour devenir député de la
3e circonscription du jura un député est
un élu qui doit être en lien avec le
terrain il doit y proche de vous pour
voter les lois à l'assemblée nationale
dans l'intérêt du plus grand nombre je
suis adjointe au maire de la ville de
dole depuis huit ans
je suis mariée maman d'un petit garçon
de 4 ans
la cellule familiale est pour moi
essentiel dans une société en mouvement
il faut être organisé pour mener de
front une vie de femme de maman et une
vie professionnelle engagée
actuellement kinésithérapeute je saurai
mettre ma capacité d'écouté de travail
et mon dynamisme à votre service je fais
équipe pour cette campagne avec jérôme
fassenet qui est un élu de terrain
agriculteur de profession je sais que ce
sera un atout pour défendre notre
ruralité
j'ai hâte de venir à votre rencontre
pour échanger avec vous cette campagne
va la vivre ensemble pour gagner cette
élection